We have yet another major court decision that
says, yes, Donald Trump's tax returns can
and should be turned over to the New York
state criminal investigators that are investigating
him, which is yet another failed attempt by
Donald Trump to prevent the release of those
tax returns.
Now I assume that this will be appealed to
the Supreme court.
Maybe by the time you watch or listen to this
story, it already will have been.
We will see if the Supreme court ultimately
takes the case.
But if so, that is increasingly Donald Trump's
Supreme court and they may well find in his
favor.
So I'll reset the details for you.
There is a criminal investigation going on
into Donald Trump and into Donald Trump's
business.
It's happening at the New York state level.
They attempted to obtain Donald Trump's taxes
and the taxes of Donald Trump's business for
the investigation.
This was blocked.
Uh, this will, this was ignored initially.
Uh, lawsuits were filed.
This went to court.
One court said it is correct and okay for
the documents to be turned over to the investigators.
Donald Trump's lawyers appealed.
And once again yesterday, another court said
it is okay for Donald Trump's taxes to be
given to the investigators.
This was the second district federal appeals
court, Trump's federal lawyer, one of them.
Another one of them.
Uh, this guy's name is William conso.
Boy.
He's been arguing all along that on the one
hand, this is merely a politically motivated
phishing expedition.
So it's wrong.
But on the other hand, he's also arguing you
can't investigate a sitting president.
Anyway.
Now the entire premise is very legally dubious.
We do have the justice department memos, which
are really about policy.
They're not about the law which say it is
not the policy of the federal justice department
to charge a sitting president.
Now that has nothing to do with investigating
a sitting president and also that's the federal
justice department.
We are talking here about the state of New
York investigating Donald Trump.
So to any sensible person looking at the basics
of this, Donald Trump is working inordinately
hard to prevent the release of his taxes.
No doubt the release of his taxes would be
bad for him.
The question is in what way would it be bad?
That's still up in the air.
Will it expose that Donald Trump isn't as
rich as he claims to be?
Would it expose financial fraud committed
by Donald Trump?
We don't really know, but what's important
to understand about this ruling is that almost
definitely it will be appealed to the Supreme
court and the release of the taxes will be
put on hold.
But just as importantly, and a lot of people
emailing me are missing this.
This is about whether Donald Trump's taxes
can be released to state investigators.
This is not about giving them to Congress
or the public.
Now they certainly might leak, but even if
the taxes are given to state investigators,
Ethan, until there's a trial of some kind
in principle, this will not make the taxes
public again unless they are leaked, which
is always a possibility.
But ultimately, if the Supreme court takes
this case and my guess is that they will otherwise
Donald Trump's taxes get sent to investigators,
it becomes up to the Supreme court, which
is made up of some justices that Donald Trump
personally selected, who will get to decide
whether our systems of checks and balances
are effectively not nullified.
And what you have to understand is that this
administration has been a total scofflaw flouting
the law on dozens of and subpoenas.
This is one we're hearing about because the
topic of Trump's taxes is more widely interesting.
But by one analysis, this year alone, the
Trump administration has either blocked or
ignored more than 86 subpoenas and requests.
We may eventually see Trump's taxes.
We may not.
But the real battleground here is that of
the long lasting importance of the issue of
what is the power of the presidency.
To ignore the checks and balances that we
have, do checks and balances that really still
exist when the president is able to get away
with ignoring any of the ones that they don't
like.
And so far Donald Trump is winning big.
I mean just like really big on that issue.
If we don't change that, um, the, the implications
will be far more far reaching than simply
during the Trump administration.
We'll take a quick break.
Give us a like on Facebook at facebook.com/david
Pakman show.
We will talk upcoming about the California
wildfires.
We will
talk about many more things as well as Andrew
Yang.
Interesting.
Andrew Yang story coming up the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible]